Neural networks are a powerful class of machine learning algorithms
and they come in many varieties
there's no way to give appropriate attention to neural networks
in an introductory video
like this here we will only identify a few key components
of a neural network and the overall work flow
so we can understand how quantum computing can contribute
the neural network is a connected graph of neurons
a neuron is basically just a thing that holds a number
and that number is often called an activation how
on or off the neuron is
the neurons are sorted in two layers
and the first layer is the input layer
and the last is the output layer
in between there are layers used in processing called
hidden layers the activation of the
input layer is just loaded directly from the data to be analyzed
such as the pixel shading in an image
the next hidden layer's activations are determined
by the neurons in the input layer
and by weights symbolized by the lines connecting all the neurons
in the input layer to all the neurons in the
next layer in other words we determine the activation
of a neuron in the hidden layer
by a awaited sum of all the
input activations we can
also apply a bias a shift
we might want to activate a neuron
in the hidden layer not just if the weighted sum is
positive but only if it exceeds a large threshold
we then often apply a complicated function to obtain an activation
between zero and one like a hyperbolic tangent
or sometimes differently a
rectified linear unit you don't need to worry
too much about these right now the only
thing important to note here about these functions
is that they are non linear
so that the network as a whole contains both linear
and nonlinear components
the same waited some of activations this time
starting with the activations of the
first hidden layer in the new weights
extends up to the next hidden layer
this continues to the final layer which is an output
the output layer has neurons corresponding to
categories and the activations tell us
how certain the network is of the classification
so the output categories in an image analysis might be
dog cat hamster and so on
and an activation of point nine five on the
dog neuron would indicate a high degree of certainty that
the image is of a dog you might start your neural network
with a random set of weights
and biases or from the known reasonable starting configuration
but then the idea is to check
how well your neural network classifies things
and improve it we use a cost function to describe
how our neural network deviates from
correct classification this involves taking the
difference between the actual value of an image
say for example a value of one on the neuron
for dog and zero on all other output nerons
and the predicted values
we some over all the categories
so we track not only whether the right category was
most activated but we can
also track if incorrect activations are reduced
within some over all the examples in our training set
and obtain a cost we then
vary the parameters like the weights in each layer
between all neurons and the biases on all their owns
classical optimisation routines are used
to search for a local minimum in the cost function
if nothing is done to reduce the complexity of this
you can imagine what an
astronomical parameter space we've set up here
consider a neural network designed to analyze images with
just a thousand pixels this neural network might have a thousand
input neurons just a single hidden layer
and binary output like cat or dog
this is the very simplest case
and still corresponds to a thousand by a thousand
or million weights between the input in hidden layers
and another two thousand between the
hidden and output layers
possibly also a thousand or
so biases so this simple neural network would correspond
to well over a million parameters thou to be fair
modern algorithms typically do make simplifications
in classical neural networks
and there are whole fields devoted to making this minimisation
possible and even efficient
but the fact remains that this is a very
high dimensional problem
and training a neural network
can be very time consuming
and costly a quantum neural network or qnn
works by first loading the input data
and then applying quantum circuits
corresponding to weights between layers
and finally a layer of measurement
a few key points about this the data
loading and the waitings are linear operations
but the measurements are nonlinear
so as in classical neural networks we have
both linear and nonlinear components
also the weight circuits
still have variational parameters
so there is still a classical minimisation to be carried out
of course this has only scratched the surface of quantum neural
networks but we hope you continue learning about the applications
of quantum neural networks
and other quantity machine learning applications
with ibm quantum